Long time no see. How have you been?
Just busy, busy.
S.
All right.
She's been busy; I don't have much else to share on that one.
For what?
I still have, I don't have much more, I've just been busy.
No problem.
All right.
OK, let's quickly jump on to the agenda. How are things going with Ketan?
Things are doing well.
Just think that's good. I want to talk to him later today. I'll find you ready to assign him more. Excuse me.
Sorry, to assign him more than just the tasks he's been doing. So I think starting next week, I'm going to assign some specific clients to act more in a L3 slash like a subject matter expert role.
I want to talk to him this afternoon. I want to see if he has a preference on companies because we got where we need to get some assigned people. So, you know, he's been asking for that, but I think now we're at the point where like, yeah, okay, it's time we can we can give this to you so I can do, you know, branch out a little bit more.
Yeah, that would be great. And I think this is what Ketan had been looking for for quite some time. So this will help him in getting where he wants to be. All right.
Mm-hmm.
Exactly.
And.
One thing is regarding.
So yeah, Ketan was asking me regarding the upcoming holiday that we have for July 1st. That's Canada Day. I know, so this is a monthly call. So next meeting of ours is scheduled on 3rd of July. But I just want to know, since you are with me here.
Mm-hmm.
Call that for first, do you would you want Ketan to avail this off, or you want him to be available to other coverage?
Does he have plants on the first?
No, as of no plans as of yet, but for 3rd of July, we have American Independence Day. So that's an offer for IT by Design India. So if he's available for 1st of July, you can give him an offer on 3rd so that he can.
Mm.
Club it with the weekend or whatever you like.
Yeah, let me let me let me bring that up when I talk to him later today, and I'll let him decide what we want, because you know, for also we're in the province of Quebec, so we have two back-to-back holidays. We have June 24th and then July 1st. So we've got the provincial level holiday and then the federal holiday right after. So I'll talk to him and we'll sort that all out.
Okay.
Then, I'll email you with his response. Ohh, we have a new person I just saw pop up. Hello.
Yep. Hey, Lee.
You are muted if you're talking.
Okay. Oh, just got another call. Okay, no problem.
I think he's connectivity issues.
All right, so let me quickly jump into the presentation deck. Ben, just give me a moment.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll quickly start with his performance side. So let me know once you're able to see it.
I can see.
Okay, so this is the billable utilization for Ketan in the past month, where obviously he's surpassing the required expectation of 80%. So he had been 90% and above throughout, averaging to 94%. The last week of the month, this is when May 25th was the holiday.
So he was on off that day, which is why his non-billable segment rose significantly more than the rest of the weeks, because this is was when he entered the eight hours as non-billable. So I have put it into the calculation. But overall, his billable average is to 94%, which is a good thing.
Mm.
Yeah, okay, yeah, I forgot about the holiday.
Any questions you have there?
I'm good.
Thank you. Next we have is the tickets resolved by Ketan. So on an average, not average, collectively, he closed 283 tickets with, you know, again, 73, 80 and 76 tickets he closed in the first three weeks of month.
Kip.
Mhm.
after May and the last week, again, because of the holiday, the number is significantly less because he was available for four days only. But still, he was able to make that cut and stay at the respectable position.
All good?
And Ben, yep, thank you. And Ben, when you said that you were considering Ketan for L3 or the same similar level of tasks, the tasks that we have mentioned here, so what would be the scope of those cases? Would it be the escalated cases that we're considering for Ketan, or is it the
I.
backed like the multiple users or the company-wide cases that we're considering in this group.
It would be so beyond, so like for more proactive tasks, maybe reviewing and handling, making sure backups are going well. Any infrastructures, things such as, you know, if a firewall has a firmware update, then let's plan on planning and deploy that kind of stuff. Maybe some more internal use, so things that kind of bubble up as proactive tasks, and then yeah, anything that gets escalated.
to my team and it's related to any client that he's assigned to, he would be handling that as the representative of my team.
Okay, so in the initial phase I presume he's gonna shadow someone.
So, we have, we have an issue on, on, we we don't have as much documentation and stuff as we would like, so...
Okay.
We basically, the team will be working together, who anybody who knows the clients or that a lot of the clients are not that fancy, especially when it comes to the cloud services. You've got the typical M365, we use one or only two different kinds of backup solutions, depending on what the customer's purchased. On-premise is a little trickier.
I.
And that's, I think, where we kind of lack our documentation. And that's where I kind of, I don't expect to just throw him in and be like, figure it out. We would all work together. You know, whoever set it up, those people are, 99% of the case are still here. We're going to talk to them. We're going to try to get the information to do documentation to make it easier going forward. And I'm not expecting him to write.
The documentation is, again, everything is a collaborative effort now, right? We're really trying to get this back into better shape.
Makes sense.
And then he would be taught, like, we have a process, like, if we're making a big change at a client, you know, they want to, you know...
And...
Implement, let's say they're buying Max for their marketing department that they've never done before. That's a big change, so it would go through to make sure everything's well documented, that everybody on the team is aware. So we've got a bit of a change management process that would follow. We want to just say, hey, figure this out. We want to plan things and basically make sure that we have the whole.
decision lifecycle tracked.
So yeah, it's just trying to get him to do more than security because I know he's a little tired of it.
I get it. But yeah, in the entire process, if you have, if you need any help from our side, please feel free to let us know. I will assist Ketan from my end. In terms of understanding knowledge, we have a team here to support him. Of course, the process has to be given by you, explained.
Mmh.
But at the same time, if any need for collaboration, any sort of assistance, please feel free to email me.
Of course.
Thank you. Is there anything else, Ben, that you want to share?
No, we're good at this time.
Lee, are you still on the call?
Looks like he is.
Okay, well, I'm all set from my side, Ben. Thank you so much for your time. As we discussed, the holiday for July 1st is something that you will talk internally with the team and let us know. So, yeah, this is it. We'll call it a meeting and our next meeting is on.
Yep.
Third of July, until then, please take care of yourself, and I'll see you next month.
Perfect. Thank you as always.
So much, bye.
Have a good day. Bye-bye.
It is.